hey guys what's going on welcome to
another hugging tutorial video in this
video we're going to be doing is adding
a pause functionality to our game so the
pause functionality is going to be a lot
very similar to where is the game intro
screen so basically the pause just we
just want to run pause for as long as
we're paused and then when we're done we
want to continue on with the game intro
the only different K Mitra game
you're like difference is with the game
intro um
actually they're pretty much the same so
game intro just happens to run before
game loop but the pause functionality
will just run within the game loop so
let's go ahead and um we just copy and
paste a game intro because we're cool
like that so come down here and just
paste game intro awesome and then we're
going to change game intro to pause and
then intro to pause and then we ask wow
pause what do we want to do the only
thing we're really checking for here as
far as keyboard events are concerned is
any sort of need sounding keyboard event
it's a really an exit out event but if
they act out the window otherwise what
do we want to do well we want to fill
with white um that's fine sort of a bit
racy we'll just say paused all of this
is fine and then button can be continued
that might be a little too big for her
button but we can also stretch out the
button so instead of 100 pixels wide it
can be you know wider if we need it to
let's see if that fits but it's probably
too fat and then quick can remain
because um yeah because it can and now
what we'll do is instead of continue
being game loop continue should
watch I'm trying to think of how I
wanted to do this very seamlessly but
now it's looking like we're in trouble
continue should because we don't want to
restart the game loop basically we want
to set pause to equal false so I suppose
right now let's just make a function
unpause and now we can't do that either
and you're really cramping my style
pause functionality um
I suppose there could be a function
within here gameloop maybe I don't think
so because we can definitely like press
P to get out of pause when I'm trying to
think of how we would get out of this
pause loop because we can definitely
quit the game that's not really a
problem but getting out of the pause
loop um we could have like unpause
unpause but the problem there is I don't
think will redefine pause equals true
unless we had it like a global variable
which we can I suppose hmm really let's
see if we can take pause we'll throw it
up as a global that seems to be the best
way about it and here uh Wow pause
that's totally fine so unpause just
needs to global pause and then unpause
pretty simple
pause equals false easy enough continue
and let's just run unpause mash your
pump let's find out a fabulous so
continue quit pause good now what we
need to do is within game intro we'll
have to set okay I'm just trying it's
hard because every time we set it pause
will be false initially like that
so then what we'll have to do is within
not game intro game loop um let's go
ahead and global pause again and then
we'll come down to this point where
we're checking for like keys and we'll
just put it right here actually we'll go
underneath this key down from
reality and we'll just say if event dot
key equals PI game dot K underscore P
and that should just be a lowercase P
that should cover that
what do we want to do well first of all
we need to set PI's to true and I think
pause was under case or lowercase right
so we need to fix that
so we global'd um pause but we set
capital P it's under case that and now
back to the P um what we want to say is
PI's equals true then we run our pause
function which also might cost trouble
so let's call the function pause do
instead that way that's not conflicting
with the variable there this is quite
the mess okay pause do and then we
unpause by the global variable which
will this is why pause and this will
global pause and turn it to false as
opposed to the game loop which turns
pause to true and then runs pause so in
my head that works we'll see what the
world of programming says and let's go
ahead and play p2 pause and now we have
continue or quit let's try continue and
let's make sure that we didn't start
over here so we've got two things dodged
let's go ahead and hit pause and then
continue and we're still continuing so
congratulations folks you did it um the
other thing we could do although in this
game I just Wow I feel like everything
sped up really fast
anyway oh man this is quite a
challenging game so and then I'll check
the quit make sure quit works but yes of
course it does so we've done that now um
that's neat now so we've got buttons
instead of requiring the user press key
keys and all that nonsense so the only
other the only major change I want to
make now to this game would be that we
need to have buttons
where are you block we need to have
buttons on the crash page because right
now it's like time sleep two seconds or
some nonsense so now we want to add this
sort of same button functionality to the
crashed as well and have like replay or
exit okay so that's what we're gonna do
in the next video so stay tuned for that
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions in to
my style